conversational experiences are critical
in today's era of omnichannel customer
support
but it's not always an enjoyable
experience we've all been on hold way
too many times only to find out that the
information we needed was available to
us the whole time through an easier path
so today i'm happy to invite john who is
at wifi and is helping companies create
great conversation ai assistance
john it's so great to have you here with
us today could you tell us a little bit
about yourself and about ryfi
absolutely my pleasure to be here as
well uh myself john matthew i'm the
co-founder and ceo of rfi technologies
from india think of us as a consumer
brand we have more than 40 million users
in 23 global languages
and then we have been again partners on
that ai front for the last 10 years so
our ai journey started in college in
2011 and over the last eight nine years
we have perfected the technology and
created an ai platform uh called sc
which is driving conversation ai
enterprise search and so on and so forth
wow
that is quite a reach
i'm curious because ai assistants are
typically pretty easy to make but what
about great ai assistance what are the
attributes of a great ai assistant and
what are the challenges you help
companies solve in this space
yeah so uh i think a great ai assistant
right from a consumer perspective should
be easy to use uh it should be smart and
most importantly people should be able
to use it on the platform of their
choice right some people prefer to
message in some people prefer to write
in an email some people would want to
dial in on an actual phone call right
that is on the user experience side but
on the enterprise side right where the
actual work happens so there also it has
to have some attributes like you know is
it going to be easy to build is it is it
going to be easy to operate is it going
to be easy to scale this whole system
and i think most importantly can it
drive revenues and at the same time
reduce costs because that is what an
enterprise at the end of the day wants
um now when we look at these aspects
right so it is important that we look at
three key perspectives to kind of solve
for these attributes that i just
mentioned so the first one is how do we
solve for training efficiency and speed
right the second one is in terms of how
do we convert content discovery into
actual commerce uh and last and most
importantly like how do we kind of
create a system uh when users can come
in and you experience the same thing
across all kinds of platforms so data
from all platforms right so that is one
key aspect because brands create a lot
of content uh some some in terms of text
something in terms of videos some of it
is structured in table some of it is not
structured so all that data has to be
utilized in order to create the
intelligence layer now what happens with
the typical chatbot is it's all rule
based or intent driven right rather than
that can it be a system wherein the
intelligence is taken from all of this
brian's data and then it becomes a smart
ai kind of a platform
now the advantage of this thing is that
whenever the data kind of changes
the whole system kind of evolves along
with it as well right
the next one is can the assistant itself
kind of reach out to the customer and
start a conversation
right think of it like you know your
customer is trying to kind of perform a
transaction or some perform some kind of
action
and maybe they drop off in between right
can your ai platform basically reach out
to that customer and try to nudge them
into completing the transaction fee
right and then last and most importantly
context is so so important uh how do we
kind of keep the threat of human
conversation because we people always
change our minds right if you look at
the typical chatbot if you want to kind
of change a context you have to say
things like you know stop exit go back
cancel and
whatnot right but ultimately what people
expect is uh can i be a system wherein i
seamlessly tell what i want and then the
system kind of actually understands and
behaves so that is the kind of platform
that we are trying to build which is at
the end of the day uh smart but at the
same time for easy to kind of maintain
for the enterprise
thank you so much for that info
so you have been helping federal bank
build this amazing ai assistant uh to
help customers get information where did
you start
so the federal bank journey uh started
several years ago i think it was in 2019
so by that time the bank had tried
around 30 different chatbot providers
and they were kind of you know before
they kind of joined us along with google
to kind of build this whole ai journey
um they had the same problem with most
of these vendors one was the data
problem right how do we kind of train
this system manually
and once it's trained how do we kind of
keep it updated because from a banking
context there is so much happening every
quarter right rbi kind of keeps updating
regulations there's so much change
happening so how does the system kind of
keep itself up to date and most
importantly understanding the nuance of
a human conversation
it's been very very difficult for them
to kind of implement right that is when
we kind of came along and tried to kind
of build this whole smart ai platform
for them for any enterprise right uh the
journey into ai starts with their data
right the data is to be consolidated and
that needs to be kind of you know become
the heart of the whole ai journey now
with federal bank we started with a very
very simple uh website based chatbot
first we deployed it on their uh
open web platform
now after that we kind of know over a
period of one year we brought them uh
into five different platforms uh it's
currently present on whatsapp it's
present on messenger it's present on
google search google business messaging
uh it's also present on voice assistants
like alexa
google assistant
and what we did there is like the slow
transition right
from giving information upfront and then
over a period of time once you started
gaining people's trust right over into
the high accuracy so there was a recent
case study that google conducted um in
which the whole platform has has an
accuracy of 98
and because of this whole uh trust
factor that we were able to build over
the last one year now we have started
triggering transactions onto the
platform wherein people can actually
perform core banking functions by just
simply talking or texting the whole ai
assistant that is fascinating one of
those core transactions it can do is
home loans so let's say i'm a federal
bank customer and i'm looking to get a
home loan
how do i request
that how does a request flow work
so currently we are working on around 18
different core banking operations and
loans as a class is one of them right
out of one of the 18 um so typically
when you when a customer basically comes
in and asks for something like you know
i need urgent cash or i am in need of
money i need i'm trying to build a new
house so that particular entry point uh
can happen on any platform uh it could
be via voice it could be via text
message it could be even by an email now
once the request comes in
then
the the whole beautiful system starts to
kind of unravel we try and understand
what the user is talking about and then
we understand that it is a loan then we
understand that this probably like a
housing loan and then trigger the
corresponding actions right now in a
specific case of the housing loan there
is a lot of manual process that is
involved you know right from sampling
for the actual space ensuring that the
properties sound and all of that so what
freddy does is it's not able to kind of
do those manual process but it
intelligently starts a process for the
home loan on behalf of the customer
right and then all the paperwork and the
system starts moving and then the bank
folks can basically call back the
customer and then continue the
verifications in order to kind of give
them the loan so if you think about what
is happening is we are staying as an
intelligence layer in the middle
understanding the user's requests
figuring out which apis to kind of
trigger and then completing the
transaction using the already secure
enterprises platform so very minimal
effort is there in terms of the bank or
any client for that matter to trigger
all of these operations
that is such a useful way to begin the
process having those early details kind
of done for you by the assistant and
then the bank staff can really focus on
doing the rest and getting back to the
customers i want to follow up with the
18 core banking operations you mentioned
before how did you determine the
priority for these 18 use cases and what
did the beginning of the development
process look like there
so the core banking functionalities uh
was a back and forth discussion with the
banking team and our team uh you know a
lot of different factors come into play
uh things like is the api readily
available how long will it take for the
bank to build that system into their
data center um and most importantly like
what are the things that the users
really want like as customers the things
that i want from the assistant now based
on all those factors it took us roughly
around three months to kind of build
that whole layout out
and then we started implementing the
functionalities one by one
now if you look at how this whole system
works right once a function
comes in
or like a question comes in it comes
into the architectural component called
the command center
think of command center as a fancy way
of saying uh this is the piece that you
know handles all the conversational
sequencing right
what is the person asking where does it
lie in the context of a conversation
what was he talking about earlier
and all of that
now here the magic of the whole system
there's two proprietary systems in play
here one is driven by google uh it's
called dialogflow that is working on
detecting the intent and the natural
language processing of the piece then we
combine it with proprietary technology
on refi end
it's called text magic and data magic
both those systems combined together
creates that context for the users
in terms of their history what would
they ask before and then sequence all of
that up figure it out and then we
leverage again powerful search system um
again called relationship maps which i
talked about earlier right the banks
content converted into these maps we
leverage this powerful search
and then the system kind of moves into
another component called the api adapter
where we try and figure out okay xy and
said core apis are required to perform
this transaction um sometimes certain
transactions are multi-stage
wherein you have to respond back to the
customer saying hey uh you know this
transaction is halfway through please
wait for another 10-15 minutes to
actually complete it and so on and so
forth uh so all that is handled at that
end then we communicate with the banks
data center to perform these
transactions
and last and most importantly one of the
my favorite pieces is called the render
engine
the whole idea is our system can be
plugged into any kind of platform so the
whole idea is you're training the ai
system once and then deploying across
platforms
so the render engine is that piece that
decides okay this person messaged in via
whatsapp i can probably be a little bit
informal in my replies and then respond
accordingly
or if the email if this was coming in an
email probably like i have to be a lot
more formal or if it comes in via voice
assistant i need to be very very precise
and then give them an answer probably
like under seven seconds because people
tend to lose their um you know their
frame of mind in that time frame or if
it's on the web i can probably like you
know throw a lot of more things like i
can probably like visualize i can
probably show more functionalities and
that
it's great to see the flow you've
created in the architecture with both
third-party and homegrown products
working together the biggest challenge
in ai assistance is context what if i
change my mind what if i'm asking about
a home loan but then i want to know my
account balance to remind me of maybe
how much i have available for that home
loan absolutely so people constantly
keep their uh you know keep their brains
turning and then changing their minds um
so here is where the proprietary pieces
of refi come in uh where the entire
sequence of the conversation is
maintained at all times uh even across
platforms right so for example if you
think about trying to perform maybe a
banking transaction on a voice assistant
like alexa or like google assistant now
you may not be able to authenticate that
via an otp right because you have to say
that odp out loud people could hear it
right so in that case the system is
interesting enough to understand that
okay i cannot do the secure transaction
on this platform can i switch you to
something more secure like an into an
encrypted messaging or i can switch you
to an email and then continue the
context there so it's not just within
one platform but across platforms this
context is always maintained and then
whenever people change their mind it
understands and then responds
accordingly the whole context is always
maintained and then we're able to kind
of swap in answer swipe out swap them
out whenever required
and then always be able to kind of you
know deliver the best experience to the
customers
wow yeah that definitely sounds like a
more enjoyable experience uh than some
of the ones i've had so thank you for
sharing that
what are some other cool things that
essie can do
um so i think another cool thing that we
have built is the whole api adapter
thing that i talked about now why that
is important in this whole piece right
because if you look at the ai system in
itself there is a lot of different
moving parts it's kind of like a
choreographing um kind of a symphony
where there is systems that are in place
to ensure the apis are not abused uh
there are like you know security systems
in place that rate limit rate check and
all of that there are systems in place
that again mask sensitive information
before being processed um and then there
are systems that again interface with
data centers for the banks or the
clients now the adapter in place what it
does is it kind of makes it very
seamless to transition between these
platforms um and then you know always
kind of churn out the best kind of
experience at a very low latency i love
to hear the word easy when we're talking
about these things
so it looks like in this case federal
bank has deployments in multiple clouds
and on premise
how do you deal with latency challenges
and an implementation like this one
so latency is a big problem in this
whole system because as you can see
there is a lot of different moving parts
that's all over the place right so we
had to kind of you know design the whole
architecture with this in mind
so that every step of the way whatever
latency can be minimized however
efficient we can make the processes that
is what is done so even the milliseconds
that we can shave off each process that
is already in place um but there are
certain areas in this whole system
wherein the latency cannot be kind of
you know controlled right so for example
when you're dealing with a core bagging
transaction uh maybe someone wants to
download a historical statement spanning
last two years or three years now this
process is going to take at least two to
three minutes on the bank side so there
is no way that api is going to kind of
respond faster right so in those cases
what we have done is we have baked in
this functionality into the render
engine wherein it can decide okay this
api is notoriously slow it is going to
take a while and what it's going to do
is going to tell the customer that okay
this is going to take maybe two to three
minutes and then whenever it is ready i
can reach back to you right so two sides
whenever latency can be cut it's already
optimized and efficiently managed and
whenever we cannot really cut the
latency because the process inherently
is slow so there we kind of you know use
a human kind of a model wherein we kind
of understand always keep the customer
informed so that they don't you know get
lost in that silence
and in specifically in federal bank's
case they are running a hybrid model
wherein core infrastructure systems are
running on aws the intelligent speech is
running on gcp uh and then there is also
the data centers in place that handle
all their core banking functionalities
what about an implementation what would
it look like if a company is already
using google cloud
so if a client is already on google
cloud uh then it's a lot more easier
because a lot of our systems are already
running out of google cloud uh we can
probably like you know align the zones
even cut the latency even further right
and then think about it uh so a lot of
the ai platforms that we use uh things
like you know text to speech speech to
text dialog flow all of them are already
on gcp itself so having the entire
system move to gcp uh definitely can
actually accelerate the entire process
so if you think about uh how the system
is designed uh from our end uh primarily
the render engine piece the data magic
piece the text magic all the proprietary
components reside within gcp
and then we again communicate with
additional systems on the google side
again residing on gcp uh so if you're a
client already on google cloud uh the
integration is pretty seamless we just
bring in the system containers and then
deploy it for you and then you we can
probably get up and running
in under six weeks
any challenges that you came across
while implementing these google cloud
services and how did you overcome them
uh not really uh
we've been working with google or for
the last several years now uh it's been
pretty straightforward implementing
these things on the platform uh and
whenever we have had uh you know minor
road bumps here and there the support
team has been very proactive they've
always kind of you know helped us you
know set that thing through yeah so i
think pretty straightforward well it's
good to hear that after seven years of
working together you have a fairly
smooth experience with cloud
so now that we've covered what getting
to this point was like let's talk about
the future a little bit and talk about
what's next for wi-fi
what are the future technical
enhancements to your architecture look
like
so if you think about this whole ai
landscape where it's been rapidly
changing and there is a renewed kind of
a focus on data and
the safety of the data the privacy of
the user and all of that right now when
you think about a company that is taking
data and processing it on cloud it's
kind of like scary for people so what we
are kind of working on now is
miniaturizing the technology in order to
be able to run on people's phones right
on device processing that is where the
personalization happens
uh and probably like the anonymized
processing will still happen on the
cloud so the architecture will probably
evolve in a fashion wherein
whatever can be done on device which is
like hyper personalized for that person
will happen on their phone itself
while the massive
large scale data systems that we run
that will kind of be on the cloud
so think about a system wherein a lot of
it will be like the heavy lifting will
happen on the cloud while
personalization will happen probably
like even offline on people's phones
that is where the whole
architecture for us is heading
oh that's so cool so users will pretty
much have access to essie at their
fingers tips at almost any time so
there's a lot to look forward to there
uh where can people go to learn more
about federal bank uh so i think these
guys are the fourth largest price sector
bank in india uh so they have deployed
their assistant on their website
federalbank.com.in
um there's a case study that google did
recently
if you like to read
that's part of the whole uh how the
system was implemented for federal bank
what are the challenges that they faced
what are the kind of statistics that
went uh or like came as outcomes um and
then last most importantly if you're
like a podcast person there is also a
cool podcast that
i did along with the vp of digital uh mr
jidesh uh so again on that there is a
lot more insights in terms of how the
whole client perspective right like um i
think there's a beautiful way uh sir
puts it uh he talks about uh
do you build a house versus do you rent
a house right and then for federal bank
their entire journey was trying to build
a beautiful house that that they dreamt
of had a lot of functionality that they
wanted they wanted to work in specific
specific ways
and then how we kind of you know help
them build that out yeah so please feel
free to check all of that out
that is super cool i will definitely go
check out that podcast to hear more from
the customer and john thank you so much
again for being here and joining us to
talk about wi-fi's great ai assistant
essie and how its architecture works
with a hybrid environment or a google
cloud environment strategy to give the
best results to
in particular enterprise customers
we definitely learned a lot today and
i'm looking forward to seeing all of the
great advances that ryfai brings to the
world of ai assistants
[Music]
you